Ron DeSantis what do you think of him as
a candidate his campaign which hasn't
even started has sort of started to
implode and this was something that I
started thinking about in September
October he really doesn't seem ready for
prime time in the sense that just being
confronted and confronted is not even
the right word just being asked about
some topics he didn't really seem to
want to talk about he responded in such
a sort of disproportionate unhinged way
during his recent trip to Asia he was
asked about why aren't you or why are
you responding but in this weird way to
Trump's attacks on you and he went into
this weird bobble head thing with a
weird smile and something came out that
didn't make any sense and he sort of got
mad at the reporter and it was just like
if you can't handle that you can't be on
a debate stage with Donald Trump and
again for all my criticisms of trump the
guy gets you on a debate stage he can
make you look pretty silly